pergunta: "Por favor, fale sobre
suplementos que possam ajudar no
tratamento de Alzheimer moderado." Bem,
queridos, vamos falar hoje sobre um tema
que toca muitas famílias de forma
profunda, o Alzheimer. Eu recebi uma
pergunta sobre os suplementos que podem
ajudar nesse tratamento e eu vou
compartilhar com vocês o que há de mais
atual na medicina funcional,
especialmente o protocolo que eu sigo, o
Dr. Dale Braden, o protocolo recode.
Primeiro quero dar uma notícia
esperançosa. Pela primeira vez na
história, temos relatos documentados de
pessoas que conseguiram reverter o
declínio incognitivo. O Dr. Braden,
depois de 30 anos pesquisando, descobriu
que o Alzheimer não é uma doença única,
mas é o resultado de múltiplos
desequilíbrios. São mais de 36 fatores
que podem contribuir. Eu sou pioneiro
aqui no Brasil na aplicação desse
protocolo. Eu fiz dois cursos recodes
nos Estados Unidos e graças a Deus temos
hoje vários colegas espalhados pelo
Brasil trabalhando dentro dessa
filosofia. Vamos aos suplementos
principais do protocolo. Primeiro
básico, o multivitamínico de alta
qualidade. Parece simples, não é? Mas
muita gente tem deficiências
nutricionais que afetam o cérebro.
Vitaminas do complexo B, que são
fundamentais B6, B9, B12, elas trabalham
juntas para reduzir homocisteína, que
quando a elevada é tóxica pro cérebro.
Sempre faça isso com orientação de
exames, se for possível.
Ômega-3, especialmente o EPA e o DHA, é
outro pilar bem importante. É tipo um
óleo lubrificante pro cérebro, tem
efeito anflamatório potente, ajuda a
manter as membranas dos neurônios
saudáveis. A dose terapêutica é bem
maior que aquela cápsula pequena que a
gente toma. Nós estamos falando aí de 2
a 4 g por dia. Agora vamos falar dos
antioxidantes. O cérebro com Alzheimer
tá sob estresse oxidativo intenso. É
como se ele estivesse enferrujando.
Então vamos usar vitaminas
antioxidantes, vitamina C, vitamina E,
gluta com enzima Q10, ácido alfalipoico.
Todos esses agentes ajudam a combater
esse processo de oxidação. É um
verdadeiro exército de proteção. Um
grupo especial são suplementos que
aumentam o BDNF. O fator neutrófico
derivado do cérebro é tipo uma vitamina
de crescimento pros neurônios. Temos a
cúrcuma, a curcumina, aquele princípio
ativo importante, é uma estrela. Nesses
casos, estudos mostram que ela não só
tem ação antiinflamatória potente, como
também aumenta o BDNF e ainda ajuda a
reduzir as placas de betamide. E tem a
bol serrata, uma resina usada a milênios
na medicina. Osidos bozuélicos que tem
nela tem ação antiinflamatória
impressionante e também estimulam
fatores de crescimento neuronal. É
medicina milenar contribuindo pra
ciência moderna. Mas olha, não é só
tomar pílulas. O protocolo recode é bem
mais extenso e personalizado. Cada
pessoa faz exames detalhados para
identificar deficiências específicas.
Pode ser que você precise de mais de
vitamina D ou mais de zinco ou mais de
probióticos. Cada caso é um caso, é
medicina de precisão e é fundamental
nesse processo a dieta ketoflex, que é
uma versão muito sensata da dieta
cetogênica, que envolve jejum também a
atividade física, atividade cerebral,
gerenciamento do estresse, gerenciamento
do sono, além de um detox guiado por
exames especiais. O Dr. Bradsen
desenvolveu até um kit específico com
seis produtos principais, infelizmente
só disponíveis nos Estados Unidos,
incluindo fórmulas para manhã e noite,
mas aqui no Brasil a gente consegue
passar por cima disso usando as
farmácias magistrais ou de manipulação.
O mais importante é entender que isso
faz parte de uma abordagem completa que
eu já mencionei com as mudanças de
estilo de vida. Eu sei, eu sei, parece
muita coisa, mas pensa assim, se fosse
seu cérebro ou de alguém que você ama,
você não faria de tudo para que fosse
possível a melhora? A boa notícia é que
temos esperança real agora. Não é cura
milagrosa, mas é um caminho com
resultados documentados e quanto antes
começar, melhor.